okay everything on fox news is narrative
journalism and they've been caught badly
and obviously editing video to remove
police with guns drawn
who work handcuffing the innocent good
Samaritan
black people at one of this week's
protests and understand that there's a
contingent that wants to put together a
very specific narrative about the
protests and that narrative is the
protesters are overwhelmingly bad and
violent they are insincere in their
activism priorities the police are good
and Trump is very good and leading the
country properly now of course there's
lots of different details that make the
reality a lot more complex protesters
are mostly good and police are mostly
good but a lot of this is about systems
of power there's the issue of Trump's
leadership constitutional issues with
the military there's endless issues here
but what I want to focus in on in this
segment is FoxNews distorting the truth
in in just a really specific way and as
Rolling Stone reports there's a local
Fox affiliate that ran a story about a
family flagging down law enforcement to
protect the business from looters when
police show up the officers handcuffed
the people who were legally holding
firearms and trying to defend this
business and fox news when they
rebroadcast this story they removed the
entire part of the story where police
drew their guns and put the Good
Samaritan black gun owners in handcuffs
so the local Fox affiliate Fox eleven
included all of that because they were
broadcasting it live you actually see
the police manhandling the victims
pulling a woman out of a car who had
nothing to do with the entire thing they
handcuffed the people who called the
cops now I can't play that for you
because local Fox stations are super
aggressive in their copyright claims and
they'll penalize my channel for doing it
but here's the the later clip from Fox
News where they remove that altogether
the police showing up and harassing and
handcuffed
the victims was casually completely
removed take a look it happened
yesterday in Van Nuys as well where
owners of a liquor store were protecting
it with their long firearms when about a
half a dozen looters showed up and tried
to hit a golden jewelry store next door
there was a standoff and there the
reporter became a witness three vehicles
drove up in front of the buy gold and
they told him get away from that and
they started arguing about it and after
they started arguing about it that's
when we started flagging you down so
they were able to stop that from taking
place I think one or two of the looters
were detained
now the there's two protests going on
right now in Hollywood what a completely
sanitized and dishonest version of what
happened
liquor store defenders with legal guns
who happen to be black defend the store
until the police show up and the full
story of course is that police showed up
aimed the guns at the people defending
the store as well as peaceful bystanders
and even handcuffed some of them this is
Fox News going as Rolling Stone says out
of its way to selectively edit the scene
and make the police appear to be nothing
but helpful and ignore the fact that the
police showed up cuffed the black people
with guns first and ask questions later
now in the video that went out live on
FOX 11 which I encourage you to check
out you can actually hear the reporter
that was on scene yelling at the police
saying these are the good guys no these
are not the looters these are the good
guys
you're cuffing the good guys and she's
insisting and the police tell her you've
got to calm down it's one of the most
chaotic insane videos that I've seen and
you know actually it's so important
really that you see this let's just play
the Fox 11 video it will probably get
flagged or whatever but you we can't
really tell the story here is the insane
video from Fox 11 live where you
actually see all the craziness go down
and you hear the reporter yelling at the
cops these aren't the bad guys you're
cuffing the good guys take a look at
this all right now they're telling them
oh my god where's the loot ergo
description black white Americans dare
show you how easily and quickly things
can go wrong or can be misinterpreted
Wow
Messina this is one of the wildest
things I've ever seen and then to see
that they're taking the woman from the
car she's not involved she just stopped
to look they actually take a random
woman out of her car cuff and detain the
Good Samaritans it is completely bonkers
so there's two parts here there's the
story of police showing up and assuming
that the Good Samaritans with the legal
guns are actually the bad guys now we
can debate is it about race is at five
percent about race is it 50% of yeah
that's one part of it then you have the
Fox News disinformation propaganda piece
of it which is that the Good Samaritans
were detained on live TV and Fox News
National has just removed that
completely from their telling of the
story and doesn't even mention it and
this contributes to the overall
narrative that Fox News has been
perpetuating the protesters are the bad
guys and they must be stopped the police
are never the problem and sometimes the
police are even actually the victims
according to some of the presentations
that are made incredible incredible
story incredible situation imagine being
that exasperated Fox 11 reporter who
sees it all go down
and then seize the police cuff the good
guys yelling these these are these
aren't the looters these are the calm
down ma'am calm down excuse us while we
pull a random woman out of her car for
stopping to see what's going on sick and
this is just one little story about so
many things
how context matters preconceived notions
selective news editing how these out of
context 40 second stories on news
channels often fail to really tell us
what's going on many lessons to be
learned here and it's also just another
one of these unbelievable videos that
you have to see to believe that this is
what's going on one of our sponsors
Nord VPN is giving you 70% off a three
year plan which comes out to just a
little over three bucks a month and
you'll get an extra month free when you
go to Nord VPN comm slash David Pakman
or just go to their site and use the
coupon code David Pakman it's 20/20
there is really no reason not to be
using a VPN not using a VPN means you
are not taking your internet safety
seriously I use Nord VPN almost any time
I'm using the Internet it hides your IP
address when you're browsing online
keeps you safe from hackers keeps
websites from tracking your browsing
activity many advantages and Nord VPN is
the most trusted VPN in the game they
don't log your internet activity like
many other VPNs do their servers are
super fast and you can even use it on
your phone Nord VPN is giving you 70%
off a three year plan that's just over
three bucks a month plus an extra month
free when you go to Nord bpn dot-com
slash David Pakman I've put a link right
underneath the video or just go to their
website and use the coupon code david
pakman